[Music]
we are here at the red carpet premiere
of spiderman no way home i am your host
megan camarena and i'm josh solay and
we're so excited to talk to the talent
and creators of this incredible film at
the iconic westwood village theater in
los angeles brought to you by marvel
unlimited your all access pass over 29
000 marvel digital comments check out
marvel.com unlimited for more
information or click on that qr code
that pops up on your screen now let's
talk to the cast and crew of spider-man
no way home exclusively in theaters
december 17th
hey marvel fans we're here with david
dussmalchen we are on the carpet right
now for marvel spider-man no way home
right now how excited for you are for
this carpet i'm so excited i'm being
back on a marvel red carpet at a
premiere for a marvel film and it's
spider-man and all the exciting things
that are about to happen in this movie
that i've just been teased by with the
trailer i'm like
i know we're all about to get our minds
blown but uh this is like historic
marvel filmmaking right now because
there's all these elements to this new
movie that we've never gotten to see
before absolutely is there anyone you're
super excited to see on the carpet today
uh i was really hoping i get to run into
alfred molina i don't know if he's
around um i mean tom and zadea and all
the incredible stars of this movie like
i'm big fans of everybody that is a part
of the movie so
i'm just
geeking out over everybody that's
awesome now spider-man is beloved by the
entire world what makes them so
relatable to you and everybody else
it's like when you're a teenager and all
of a sudden your everything starts
changing and the world seems like it
doesn't make any sense peter parker is
the embodiment of that for all of us
he's like his body starts changing all
these things start happening that he has
no control over and all of a sudden he
has this choice to make like what am i
going to do with all this change am i
going to do something
to make the world better or am i going
to
turn all that anger and confusion and
fear into something dark and he
continues to inspire us because over the
decades peter parker and spider-man
continue to rise the occasion and be the
hero that we need them to be i
absolutely love that hope positivity
enjoy the red carpet thank you so much
for being here thank you thank you
thanks everybody
[Music]
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
chris mckenna and eric summers the
writers of the film y'all have so much
to juggle in this there are so many
characters where do you even begin
uh
we uh we didn't know where to begin we
honestly we
after the last movie there were a lot of
different things that we couldn't do in
a lot of uh in a good way i think uh
those kind of limitations are good but
once the idea the multiverse opened up
to us uh obviously there was an infinite
number of ways to go and uh
almost uh
an embarrassment of riches in terms of
what we had to choose from but also
restrain ourselves because we knew we
had to tell one story
yeah i would just say that with the uh
the other with the preceding two
spider-man movies we always had to and
with this one we we had some
housekeeping to do dealing with the
larger mcu and other things that had
happened and
we had limitations always a lot of which
were fun to deal with but in this one in
addition to that we then just had this
this door opened to the multiverse and
just a truly an infinite number of
possibilities and it was almost
overwhelming and it took us a long time
to just talk and talk about it and
realize like what is what is the most
fun we could have with it and hopefully
we did and with the multiverse we have
super villains from previous spider-man
films in this what was it like to write
for those characters
daunting
it was really daunting
uh you know we would all we'd already
watched those movies so many times but
now we had to really watch them
again and really
try to live up to um make sure we're
living up to the characters but
you know i mean
sam raimi is a hero of us and mark webb
is an incredible incredible filmmaker we
wanted to do
justice to the worlds that they created
but also make sure that they fit
into
the world that you know that we've been
so honored to be a part of so it was a
juggling act you know it really was
it's funny you know the the
the the previous spider-man movies are
movies that i would find myself quoting
with friends or just in a room with
writers discussing something for
reference and this is the first time
where suddenly in my career i was
writing for those characters that i just
thought were like some kind of amazing
reference or something i was a fan of
and yeah it was daunting it was daunting
but it was also really really fun
[Music]
what's up marvel fans i am here with jv
smoove what is up how are you my wife
shawn
shaw xo this lovely lady saw xo right
here
so beautiful tonight i love this thing
on you like cotton candy wow thank you
thank you
and we love cotton candy gosh i like it
here this is great you guys are great
can you stay here all night this is nice
you both look incredible i feel like
that has to be stated you guys look
wonderful
i have a question what has mr dell been
up to since we last saw him
mr dell has been
his superpower is the power of knowledge
you know unlike these amazing powers
that spider-man has
his power lies in books his power lies
and motivating these young people to
become better uh versions of themselves
and that's his power it's an amazing
gift amazing gift of power and i'm a man
of science mr dale is truly a man of
science as you saw in the previous movie
um he just wants to make sure these
young people get the exposure to science
that they need science makes the world
go round
i like that that's a superpower we all
have yeah uh what are you most excited
for uh with the film tonight i want to
see my husband like of course i love
spidey
but this is my man like i can't wait to
see him do its thing in it so that's my
truth
no i love that that's so exciting um uh
so everyone knows peter parker
spider-man how does mr dell react to
that how does he feel about it mr dell
was pretty upset
when you have a student's back for all
this time and you find out something
like this that they didn't tell you and
you felt you had a close relationship
with this student
and this is what happens you know they
pull the wall of your eyes and you find
out something like this mr dale was
pretty upset
he was not too happy about that a little
heartbreaking
he thought they were like like this but
it turns out they were like this
it'd be like that sometimes
well it was so lovely talking with you
guys having an amazing rest of your
night and enjoy the movie it's gonna be
fabulous we cannot wait
[Music]
[Music]
hi marvel fans i'm here with aryan moyet
how's it going how are you feeling i am
feeling overwhelmed excited i cannot
wait to see it on a big screen i'm like
over the moon about this whole thing how
does it feel to be a part of the mcu
it's surreal i'm not gonna lie to you
it's completely surreal to be a part of
marvel you know i was born in iran and
so to have that be from there to here is
a real surreal moment for me so i really
really uh
you know i'm just i'm just honored and
blessed really oh that's so good to hear
well i'm excited for you what are you
looking forward to most in the film
tonight
i am looking forward to my selfishly
i'm looking forward to my interrogation
with ned
spoiler okay okay um but most like most
what i'm really looking forward to is
watching tom holland and watching all
these folks make these amazing human
beings come to life i mean that's what
i'm looking forward to i mean this is
big this film everyone knows who peter
parker's secret identity is a spider-man
how does your character feel about that
obviously he does he's he's
interrogating him so he comes in and
really interrogates the group and really
kind of tells them listen
you shouldn't have done that you know um
anyway i'm really just excited to be
here and be a small part of this movie
[Music]
what's up marvel fans i'm joined by
paula newsom how's it going it's going
great this is terribly exciting no we
don't know too much about your character
what's it like joining the mcu you know
what i'm gonna tell you that
when twitter started kind of going to
gog they thought i was mj's mama not to
say that i'm not you know what i'm
saying but what's really fun about this
is joining this it's like
coming into halftime when the when the
game's already going and you jumping in
it's like i gotta keep up i gotta keep
up i gotta keep up it's fabulous yeah
well i bet you did amazing so everyone
knows that peter parker is spider-man uh
how does your character feel about that
you know she's not so enthused by him
i'm not gonna give away too much and
that's the t
that's true she doesn't much like him
that much because he's not impressed
i mean what do you got what do you got
whoa
okay i i'm taking that i'm gonna keep
that i'm gonna hold that while i go into
the theaters what are you excited to see
tonight
i'm excited to see the movie in its
entirety john watts our director is
amazing i got to work with an amazing
group of actors fred molina
tom you know we were there for a month
in the middle of atlanta just
along with my stunt double it was just i
look forward to seeing the whole thing
you know the whole multiverse vibe
come on now
i mean you chose a great time to show up
i'm just saying well i don't want to
keep you you have the rest of the red
carpet to go and enjoy the film
congratulations again thanks love
[Music]
[Music]
hey marvel fans i'm joined by sarah finn
how are you doing hello i'm great it's
very exciting to be here tonight how are
you
i'm i'm speechless this is incredible
what has it been like to see these young
adults that you cast
grow into the characters that there are
now
yeah it's a little emotional isn't it
to think about the journey and when we
first cast tom and zendaya and jacob i
think jacob's screen test was his first
time he ever set foot on a set in his
life and now to see how far they've come
and have the end of the trilogy here i'm
very excited to see the movie i haven't
seen it yet very excited to see it and
uh to see how the fans react well you've
done an incredible job at casting like
it's this
kudos to you
what was it like bringing back
characters like willem and uh alfred am
i allowed to talk about that i don't
think so megan
i mean it was in the trailer come on
sarah i think you can yeah um it's
bonkers it's this movie is uh as big as
anything we've ever done and it's really
exciting to see how they're all going to
interact on screen together did you ever
think that would happen
no i didn't i didn't when i first heard
the idea for the movie i thought this is
impossible but
but here we are here we are okay
was there a moment where you're like i
don't know if we can pull this off this
is so big this is the biggest spider-man
film yet yes luckily on my end a lot of
the cast was already in existence that i
had cast and from other wonderful
casting directors who worked on this
film in much earlier versions so in
terms of pulling it off i'm going to
toss that ball to the incredible
production people our producers amy
rachel kevin feige john watts everyone
who worked so hard to pull off a movie
on this scale
[Music]
hi marvel fans i am here with victoria
alondo executive producer how are you
doing great i'm excited now zendaya is
coming so that's the party right there
we got a party going on here too we we
had a yes today is a good day today is a
good day we get to celebrate spider-man
one of my favorite characters not not
their favorite but one of my
one of mine nice save
and they're all my favorites tonight is
a big night this is the biggest
spider-man film
that we've seen today and the effects
and are on a whole nother level can you
talk about that just a little bit just
there's just so much that went into this
you know the thing about working on
these things it just feels during the
pandemic this took
far more effort because we were not
together
and i think that what i longed for is to
be together again but we got it done
thanks to the six thousand plus people
across the world so i thank every single
vendor facility
human artist and family member that put
up with us working from home and
hopefully you can all go see it and
keep the secrets
i thought you were going to tell us the
secret
i'll say no are you kidding me
i don't know i'm not saying anything
okay all right all right well what are
you most excited about with this film
tonight i'm excited to see how people
react to something that we've been it's
been with us for so long
so i'm just ready
ready for all of you to know what i know
okay well i'm ready for that too um
how did you and your team pull this off
um
well you know every movie takes a lot of
effort so it just it was uh effort
effort effort and we have the best team
you know amy kevin we have john watts
who's fantastic and we have a beautiful
trio and zendaya and tom and jake and
the friends are back they're back in
town so they get to tell another story
that's beautiful
what does this night mean to you
i hope i hope that this gift of
filmmaking that we put out there to the
world is received with as much love as
we made it
that made my heart feel like mushy i
love that well i don't want to keep you
enjoy the rest of your red carpet i look
forward to seeing the film thank you
thank you for your support and if i
don't see any more i think that's it for
this year we have nine projects that
came this year happy holidays we
represented with all of our hearts so
we'll see you after this we'll see you
next year all right see ya thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hey marvel fans we're here with amy
pascal this is an incredible movie what
does it feel like to get this off the
ground running
yes it's fantastic people are out people
are excited people love spider-man it's
great so spider-man talking about the
love of spider-man he's so relatable
what makes spider-man so beloved by all
i think because spider-man means
something different to everyone at
different ages in their life you know
when you're a little kid it means one
thing when you're a teenager or
something else and when you're grown up
something else
you know it's a boy who's always
struggling with
being good
and i think we all understand that
we were able to bring the super villains
from previous spider-man into this film
what was that process like it was
fantastic because of course i had worked
with all of them on the other films and
it was really exciting to bring them
back out of your entire spider-man
journey what are you most proud of
tonight
of course i love it amy thank you so
much enjoy the movie thank you so much
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
john watts the director and family so
john is an incredibly incredible
director we've seen two spider movies
already what makes him so amazing
well he's our brother he's a baby
brother yeah he's our baby brother i
wanted to bring my family on the red
carpet just because
uh you know historically spider-man's
out there helping regular people that's
what he does and my family
literally does that my brother's a
firefighter my sister's a nurse my other
sister here is a teacher and they're
like actually out there on the front
lines
legitimately helping people over this
past like terrible year and a half so i
just wanted to sort of take a little bit
of the spotlight off of me and shannon
on them and all the people that have
been doing great things to help people
in this like really tough couple of
years that's that's amazing that that's
incredible
so john just spoke about how
you inspire him how does he inspire you
oh my goodness i bring him to red carpet
events
they get to meet tom holland and
zendaya now this is a huge huge film
where did you even begin
well at the end of the last movie we
kind of
gave ourselves a really big
uh ending where we revealed peter's
identity so um
we started there
straight to the point i love it now
super villains from previous spider-man
movies are in this film
what was it like to be a part of that oh
it was great i mean i'm a fan of those
movies so to have them
there i was just being a nerd like
everyone else
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
simulu what is going on we're here at
the live carpet how does it feel uh it
feels pretty great i'm i'm not sure that
these people
realize that i'm not in this movie
i think they you know
i'm not gonna burst their bubble for
them no spoilers no spoilers no spoilers
at all anything is possible but i'm also
not in this movie
maybe
so
who are you most excited to see in this
film um
i'm excited to see spider-man
question mark i'm excited to no no i
mean i i've been i've been reading the
rumors like everybody else i'm so
fortunate to get to be here to get to
watch this movie early
and um i'm just excited to see where
they take it i've been such a fan of the
spider-man movies ever since toby
maguire i think it's just been a really
long ride and a full circle moment for
a lot of people so i'm i'm jazzed i'm
excited we're talking about that
previous super villains are in this
movie what was your reaction when you
found out
uh i was pretty okay okay well first of
all i was like oh my god doctor octopus
is in the trailer and then i was like oh
my god like jamie foxx is there as
elektro and then it was like oh my god
he's got the stark tech on his on his
armor so i was like what does that mean
i feel like everyone was you know pretty
blown away by all of that i think you
know i i work for this company so i know
people at marvel they're master
marketers they're they're you know
they're mysterious they work in
mysterious ways they operate behind a a
veil of secrecy and shadow
um and and you know i'm just excited i'm
so excited that i finally get to take a
peek
behind and see what they've been cooking
up you know i feel like
i i deserve to be here because i used to
play spider-man at kids birthday parties
i dressed up i i inhabited the character
um
you know i was in the costume i i really
i feel like i was spiderman so in a way
i do feel like this is my premiere can i
still hire you for birthdays is it too
late um you can but the rate is now 75
000 an hour yes it's gone up a little
bit it's yes
thank you have a good one take it easy
[Music]
unlock the marvel universe of comics on
your device in one all new all different
app gain instant access to over 29 000
digital comics with incredible new
issues added every single week
dive into exclusive stories that will
forever change what you know about the
mighty marvel universe
swing through infinity comics available
only on marvel unlimited
there's so much more for you in the app
true believer get started today
what's up marvel fans i am here with
benedict wong how are you hello hello
ecstatic excited bit tired blurry-eyed
from 5am um
uh work call but uh
as soon as i get in there well these are
waking me up as well actually so um
oh it's just fizzing with excitement you
know ah this it's an exciting time to be
here
so uh you've been busy uh wong has been
very busy in marvel studios strong chi
the legend of the ten rings
now spider-man uh no way home and not to
mention your upcoming film dr strange
and the multiverse of madness there's a
lot weighing on wong's shoulders how's
he handling it um i'm okay with the plum
i got an email from kevin feige saying
it's fast becoming the wcu so i'll i'll
take that um so here we are the wong
cinematic universe i like it i like it
definitely um well what is it like to
get a chance to dive into the marvel
multiverse uh with all the weird
creative worlds that it entails
well uh
we certainly have to do
a lot of versions and it's also kind of
filming as well during this sort of kind
of
time as well where we're kind of like um
you know if something happens you know
then we we hit plan b we hit plan c so
we're kind of
living in a sort of quantum film filming
um
uh schedule you know so that's how it's
been that must be crazy as an actor
yeah i mean i call it like the mantis
said the multi-schedule that's it really
you know dr strange that well before you
leave what's something that you can tell
us that the fans can look forward to
maybe a little tease
well you know there'll be a shift i
think definitely um
in this which will uh hopefully you know
we'll see
a different responsibilities i think you
know
[Music]
marvel fans i am here with marissa tonay
how's it going i'm going good getting
very excited for everyone to see this
movie it's the big the big opening the
energy is amazing i'm so excited yeah
it's very it's really thrilling so what
has may been up to since we last left
off
uh
well her and peter parker have gone
through a lot together they're growing
up they've been through several cycles
of on and off relationships with other
people
i don't know they're hanging out
i mean that's a lot
uh so everyone knows that peter parker
is spider-man how is may handling that i
think that well well may was shocked at
first
and then
you know then she found out and
they became a team they just really work
together
and
um
she's in on it with him and she also
tries to protect the part of him that's
still a boy and lets him do his thing i
love that so i need you to spill the tea
all right
may has kind of a different
understanding when it comes to her
relationship with happy
ah
is there a relationship there what's
going on i don't i don't think i mean
there's a relationship there's a
friendship and they've also they're like
compadres they've been through so much
together they've been lovers they've
been friends they've been on they've
been off i don't know why you think i
have a different why do you have a
different understanding i mean the last
movie it was kind of like a little back
and forth oh yeah yes yes yes true
uh what was it like to work with this
incredible cast again oh it's just so
great to see uh to see them they're
always doing something new and different
and they they just they're so beautiful
they're beautiful to look at they're
beautiful inside and uh it's always fun
to come back and be with them again well
i'm excited to see you on the big screen
tonight i won't keep you from the red
carpet thank you for spending time with
us thanks thanks to you
[Music]
[Music]
marvel fans i am joined by sochi gomez
how's it going i'm doing great i'm
nervous i'm excited
what are you looking forward to seeing
most in this film tonight um well number
one my homies uh benedict cumberbatch
and benny wong got to support the crew
i'm really excited to see uh just this
movie in general
um have you been a spider-man fan for a
long time oh yeah
um like who hasn't been since like five
years old i mean are you kidding me
that makes sense you're you're right so
there's quite a bit of crossover between
the cast and the cast in your upcoming
film uh marvel studios doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness
what is it like working with uh benedict
cumberbatch and bennett wong oh i mean
it's pretty insane i'm a pretty looking
person it's pretty crazy i just love
watching them getting their character in
their zone and it's just been a
wonderful like teaching experience
honestly um it's just crazy to be like
oh my gosh i know these people it's kind
of funny
i bet who are you excited to see most on
this red carpet tonight
zendaya
zendaya girl yes i'm excited i'm like
i'm looking here now i'm waiting for the
screen i know
there i hear some screams it could be
her
uh so i heard you skateboard is that
true yes i i do a little bit of
skateboarding but ever since i started
getting some like rolls i was like i
can't really injure myself here so
i i just i just graze a little bit no no
crazy trick no no no no
i might be able to have like some fake
blood and stuff for work but
not nothing nothing in real life that's
a cool skill to have and you just
celebrated your quinceanera yes i did it
was it was during coven and stuff so i
couldn't really have some like huge
thing which i mean i really wish i could
have but i just went around the park and
around just la and just took some photos
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
jacob batalon who plays ned leads this
is a huge film where do we start with
ned in this one oh my goodness ned is
reeling you know his best friend's
identity just been revealed to the world
so he's just like what does he do next
what are the fos up to now like we're
planning what to do it's crazy
does ned get to get on the action on
this one oh my goodness like you
wouldn't believe ned and mj are killing
it
yes so what was it like working with
benedict cumberbatch i mean unbelievable
he's like so professional but also such
a funny amazing human being and everyone
on the cast has been amazing every like
every legend that's been on has been
just amazing so we know ned's arc
throughout these films but what has been
your journey through this i feel like i
mean i've accomplished everything that
i've wanted to accomplish with ned i
feel like he's definitely become the guy
in the chair to like in the action so i
think in that way he's had a great time
so yeah if you can have any spider-man
gadget in real life what would you
choose uh probably the web wing so i can
fly
that's awesome jacob thank you so much
enjoy the movie thank you
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with jk
simmons who plays jay jonah jameson what
was it like to come back for this
spider-man film
uh always a pleasure whatever
incarnation i hope they keep
reincarnating jjj now what's the
difference between this jay jonah
jameson and the one you played
previously only the hair really
so this film is so massive what was it
like working with this incredible
ensemble
well i'm telling you i was in and out i
still haven't met
two-thirds of the cast of this movie i'm
hoping i get that opportunity tonight so
who you excited to see tonight
uh the kids who play spider-man whatever
his name is and uh you know the 75 bad
guys
some of whom are you know old leftovers
like myself and some new ones throughout
your spider-man journey do you have a
favorite moment
can't pick one i'm not gonna even try
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
john favreau who plays happy hogan now
you started the mcu directing marvel
studios iron man what is it like to
continue that legacy of iron man as
happy hogan well i love being a part of
this as an actor because i get to
continue to work with the people that i
work with on the iron man films
also even before i started directing i
remember visiting the set of of
spider-man 3 that was my first
experience
so it all feels it's nice that it's all
coming together and i'm just happy that
i've been able to be a part of it in one
way or another for decades now
that's awesome now the entire world
knows who spider-man is how does that
affect happy
well it's you know happy's always been
in on the secret with tony stark uh with
with peter parker so happy was always
good at being a professional wingman to
help out and make help them navigate
their way through all the challenges of
uh of being a superhero i think he
offers a lot of moral support i don't
think he's
i don't think he's too good for
protection even though he's supposed to
be head of security but i think he's a
good friend and i think for peter parker
he was a good uh
i think he took it upon himself to look
after him after tony was gone so i
really like playing that part and i
really like tom holland a lot and i love
i love popping onto the set and working
with uh john watts and everybody there
uh it's a great group of young actors
and as an actor i love it and i think it
comes through in the character that's
awesome now do you have a favorite mcu
moment in spider-man through your
journey
oh and spider-man i like when we're in
the bathroom i think we're in the
bathroom together
where i'm trying to be like nick fury
popping into his high school
and i and i confront him
and uh and someone flushes the toilet so
my really cool like nick fury moment is
completely undermined
by uh by by a toilet flushing yeah i
like that one a lot that's awesome john
thank you so much enjoy the movie thank
you have a good
[Music]
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
willem dafoe who plays green goblin all
right what was your reaction when you
were told the premise of this film
uh sounded good good enough to sign on
in order to revisit this character
now what was it like revisiting that
character how was that it was great i
mean it's uh
yeah it's a continuation and uh this is
probably the most ambitious film in this
series so far
so it was great to be a part of it
see some old friends see some new
friends you know that's incredible what
was it like working with director john
watson the awesome ensemble he was great
i mean uh
you know they had a lot of people had
worked together before so they were
really had good chemistry already and a
lot of trust and yeah it was it was fun
to work uh
you know very loose but also uh you know
we were we were making our days and
having fun do you have a favorite
spider-man moment in the mcu
oh god that's that's a tough one yeah
too hard again yeah there's so many i
you know i enjoy doing the action stuff
[Music]
marvel fans i am here with jamie foxx
who plays electro
what is it like returning to this
character after all this time it's been
amazing man like to be able to reboot
the character new look new vibe and my
kids here with me representing electro
they got the shoes the representative
electro they got the shoes so we just
been uh you know just been happy to be
on this ride and can't wait for the
world to see the movie what's different
about electro this time well the way he
looks right off the bat uh it's a
different look he's simplified um potent
kind of got a flyness to him and so
everybody online has been you know
really like reacting well to it so just
can't wait for people to check it out i
heard you brought your own flavor to it
yeah yeah you know you got to bring your
flavor to it so you know the fact that
they were allowing you know
accommodating with that makes the whole
movie feel better
yeah well i'm excited to see it um
what's the best part about playing a
super villain oh it's always good to be
a bad guy it's good being bad you know
what i mean so it's like you're doing
electro there's so many layers when
you're a super villain you know what i
mean so i can't wait for you to check
that out
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we're here with
kevin feige this is a huge undertaking
of a film where did you start
uh we started at the ending of far from
home where we knew that we had put peter
parker in a very hard
circumstance where his identity was
revealed and from there we decide what
happens next and how do we make things
harder for him he's been to space he's
become
spider-man he's lost his mentor and now
his identity is revealed and all he
wants to do is graduate high school and
go to college and we started there and
the good old parker luck kicked him
you brought super villains in from
previous spider-man movies into this
what was that process like uh it was
very emotional it always starts with a
place of what do we think would be fun
what do we think would be cool i've been
making movies for 20 years now at marvel
and they started at this very theater as
a matter of fact with the premiere of
sam raimi's spider-man one
and we were sitting around a room and
saying if i saw willem dafoe who you
just talked to is green goblin again and
alfred molina who's not able to be here
tonight is doc [ __ ] i would lose my mind
just that just that starting point um
and uh and a lot of luck came together
that that they were interested we were
able to bring them back oh that's
incredible i can't wait to see this
incredible film what are you most proud
of throughout this spider-man films well
i'm proud of the collaboration we've had
with with john watts on three movies
with tom holland on three of his own
movies plus the avengers movies the
entire relationship between sony and
marvel and disney is really
unprecedented in hollywood history and
it's all because everybody loves
spider-man and and that is amazing i
hope it shows in all the movies as well
we said everyone loves spider-man what
makes them so lovable and relatable
uh i think that was the genius of what
steve ditko and stan lee did all those
years ago was they made him us they made
him flawed and related and again here he
is in this giant anticipated movie that
may or may not have consequences for the
multiverse but peter parker just wants
to go to college peter parker just wants
to graduate high school that's it
uh and and
you you you want to root for that person
kevin thank you so much enjoy the movie
thank you so much have a good night
thank you
[Music]
marvel fans i am here with zendaya mj
herself how are you i'm good how are you
i'm doing pretty great so i have a
couple questions this is the biggest
spider-man film yet and there's a lot of
stunts how did it feel to be web
slinging and flying high oh man it was
so much fun i love being able to do that
stuff especially because we feel
incredibly safe we have an amazing stunt
coordinator and um
you just you just get to have fun i i'm
not afraid of heights in that way so i
feel really good about it yeah well i
can't wait to see how has mj changed
since we last seen her um i think she's
just opening up more i think now that
she has
has peter in her life and and someone
and ned of obviously people who feel
that love her for who she is i think
she's able to slightly just open up a
little bit more and maybe even be a
little bit more positive because usually
she's like the nihilistic friend right
she's the one that's always looking at
things glass half empty so it's nice to
see that side of her
[Music]
hello marvel fans we're here with
benedict cumberbatch who plays doctor
strange you have had quite the busy life
my friend yeah what is it like to dive
into the marvel multiverse uh
marvel is a fun place to be right now as
dr strange that's all i will say and
yeah you know he he brings something
very interesting to this film
but most of all having worked with tom
not just on this but on a couple of
other projects it's just it's just
wonderful to be by his side again and
doing what we do and establishing and
maturing and growing that relationship
is fantastic what is it like bringing dr
strange into the world of spider-man uh
a lot of fun a lot of fun you know i get
to play the grown-ups surrounded by kids
i can say that they're half my age they
are kids i'm blown away by their
professionalism by the atmosphere they
create on set by the fun it is to be on
that set john watts is a phenomenal
director he's such a joy to work with he
really he's great on the granular he
gives you context to understand where
your place is in the story and the
development of it even when all the
story hasn't been finished which is
often the way with these films at the
time of production starting and it is
just fun from start to finish
what goes through doctor strange's mind
after saving worlds and universes a
young peter parker comes up saying hey
can you craft a spell to have people
forget
i think the first thing that goes
through his mind is to see in the film
it's like yeah sure i want to help you
out kid you did great back there and uh
you're one of them and us and you know
we're doing we're all on the same team
here so sure help a friend out
it doesn't really take into account that
he's still a kid at high school
and
in trying to people please or going yeah
okay let's do one for the team yeah
some crazy stuff is unleashed and um
and that's where the the relationship
starts to evolve and material and that's
what i'm really excited about i mean
there's some crazy reveals and fun
spills and thrills in this but also
for me as an actor the thing that
matters most is that emotional
connection to a character and and the
people uh who surround him and the world
that surrounds him so with tom and i
that's that's a really beautiful
relationship that's kicking off
[Music]
what's up marvel fans we are here with
tom holland who plays peter parker this
is one of the biggest spider-man films
ever made
what was your reaction when you read the
premise
oh man i was blown away i was also so
skeptical i just at the time i was like
there's no way that they could pull this
off there's no way that they'll be able
to bring these villains back into this
universe and make it make sense
but they did and they've done it in a
wonderful fashion the movie is
incredibly heartfelt it's funny it's
emotional it's exciting and you know
john watts has really knocked out the
park so to be here tonight celebrating
this movie
i honestly cannot even begin to explain
to you how happy i am and how excited i
am if you had told me 10 years ago that
you'll be playing spider-man in a movie
like this i would have been like you're
a liar
well in a movie like this exactly look
at all look at all these people they
love you movie like this you're playing
opposite super villains from previous
spider-man movies what is that like
it's incredible yeah i mean i've been a
huge fan of these movies
since i was a kid i remember seeing
toby's movies i remember seeing andrew's
movies so to get the chance to share the
screen with their villains has been one
of the most rewarding aspects of my
career and i'm so lucky to be here
tonight i can't wait to share the night
with them and i'm seeing tom rothman
over there my boss who i love he's been
so kind to me i want to go and give him
a big hug and honestly i am beyond
excited
peter goes through so much the death of
tony stark mysterio letting him know his
entire identity what is that like for
peter parker in this film it's tough i
mean everyone's been asking me in the
press can you relate to it because
you're famous but i'm famous for making
movies and he's famous for being a mass
murderer so it's slightly different uh
but it's you know been a very exciting
challenge something i've really enjoyed
taking on bringing to life in the
character it definitely totally shifts
the movie it makes the movie feel very
different to the previous two which is
great i love change and i love this
movie and i love everyone here and it's
awesome tom you got a busy night enjoy
the premiere thank you so much thank you
have a good one
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh that was amazing it was incredible so
many talented actors the cast the crew
i'm speechless as am i let us know what
your favorite interview was in the
comments below and be sure to check out
marvel unlimited your all access pass
over 29 000 marvel digital comics and
check out marvel.com unlimited for more
information or click on that qr code
when it pause up on the screen and be
sure to check out spiderman no way home
exclusively in theaters december 17th
this is marvel your universe